the African elephant is in a great deal
of trouble the most comprehensive census
shows the population decreased by a
third in just seven years yet this is
Namibia where the wild is still wild and
the numbers are going up here where they
believe the preservation of these
magnificent creatures is down in large
part to the conservation benefits of
trophy hunting hunting and killing these
creatures generates hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year for Namibia
it's all managed by communal
conservancies which restrict the number
of trophy hunting permits take a tough
line on poaching and that they argue is
how they're helping the elephants
survive here it's taken two years but
finally a professional hunter has agreed
we can join him on a hunt it's on the
understanding we don't identify his
American client who's paid a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars to hunt a range
of animals his priority though is
elephant and getting a trophy tusks
which he'll take back to Texas no
there's a whole idea that's probably at
least thirty elephants their aim is to
find an old bull elephant they travel on
their own or in small groups cows calves
and young bulls are off-limits for these
hunters and do your instincts kick in at
this stage where you think we are making
progress absolute a lot elephant to find
a big old one and there's a really good
track yes the signs are very positive
with the elephant dung still warm
the hunters know they're closing in but
despite their size they move quickly and
almost silently we've been walking
through the store for 15 minutes just
trees knocked over and broken and it's
the way it is to see the wind direction
this time of day it will swell and then
the animals are small I'm still checking
the wind direction
finally after hours of tracking they get
a clearer sight of a group it's a very
big old elephant bull there but they
were too clustered together so on
schedule even as they non went beyond
the right side now I just follow them
until they start feeding they've got a
little spooked with a small test which
walked so I'm just going to follow them
my biggest elephant to come out of this
area this year
they identify a mature male the drawback
for the client is the ball only has one
tusk it's left one has broken off hunter
and prey stand looking at each other for
several minutes just 30 meters between
them the animals are in too much of a
huddle so they wait the intention is to
fire one decisive shot it doesn't quite
work out that way
wounded now with two bullets in him the
bull breaks off from the group and flees
for his life with the hunters close
behind I always prefer a quick ending
and but with all the bulls around us
like that it was very very difficult to
get him closer and also then get a brain
shot which is what we prefer was its
instantaneous and we shot him on the
shoulder it takes more than four hours
to find the wounded creature okay come
with me this time there'll be no escape
shoot him shoot him
reload
walk up shoot them right between me yes
that's that's that's always emotional we
attack an elephant Julius we kill them
because we love them I want them to
survive my young daughter must see them
she must see in the world not a zoo and
we have to we have to it's not just the
professional who was emotional his
client - breaks down crying before
posing for photographs with his trophy
we tracked this elephant passes this
village and the local people here will
tolerate the elephant in the area
they'll tolerate them being here because
they know that a lot of people here
employed a lot of people here gain from
the revenue livelihood and then the meat
will be distributed in the next 24 hours
and everyone in this area will have meat
and we taking one old bull out of
population so that those 150 elephants
we saw yesterday can occupy this area
but the argument is a highly
controversial one and many believe the
financial benefits in many African
countries aren't always handed back to
the community
the namibians insist theirs is a success
story and we were shown villagers
stripping the animal of its meat the
five-ton creature will provide meals for
dozens and dozens of villages the
hunting also provides jobs and the
government believes if the community
sees the benefits they'll be less likely
to kill the animals themselves or allow
them to be poached and those who have
seen their lives
change of fervent advocates I'm like the
breadwinner of the family everybody
depends on me so how many people is that
then I'll say oh my kids and my brothers
and my breath kids my sister's kids my
mom since I don't have a father now so
I'm the father of the incas the ivory
toss though will go to the American
hunter and eventually sit in his home
they would fetch a hundred thousand
dollars on the black market although
he's not allowed to sell them but
Namibia's arguing for the ban on all
international trade and ivory to be
lifted and they want their elephants
removed from the site he's protection
listings altogether they argue by
killing a set number of their elephants
it gives them a value and everyone else
an incentive to conserve them it's an
argument that's going to be difficult to
win Alex Crawford Sky News in Olivia